el puerto de Nicolás Fue llamado por
meses la ciudad mártir Y es que se
convirtió en ese tapón que impedía que
las fuerzas de Moscú fueran camino hacia
ese otro gran Puerto en el mar Negro la
ciudad diodesa que desde el comienzo de
esta invasión a gran escala Era uno de
los objetivos del presidente Vladimir
Vladimir Putin al comienzo de la
invasión a finales de febrero y
comienzos de marzo las tropas rusas
Estuvieron muy cerca de esta ciudad y si
bien las fuerzas ucranianas lograron
hacerlas retroceder estuvo por meses al
alcance de la artillería y era atacada
sistemáticamente por bombardeos por
artillería decenas y decenas de
edificaciones fueron destruidas y la
mayor parte de la población tuvo que
huir debido a Ese temor y a esas
situaciones en las que se encontraban
sumado a eso por muchos meses y
actualmente siguen teniendo
de agua lo que hacía aún más difícil la
vida pero la situación sin embargo
cambió a partir de noviembre cuando las
fuerzas ucranianas lograron recuperar el
control de la ciudad de gersón desde
entonces esa ciudad tiene hoy las mismas
circunstancias de Nicolás entonces esa
tocada constantemente mientras aquí ha
llegado una relativa paz Pues si vienes
alcanzada por esos misiles que alcanzan
otras ciudades de Ucrania su situación
no es diferente ha vuelto la gran parte
de la población o un buen número de ella
y hoy vemos domingo una gran cantidad de
gente caminando por la calle un
escenario que era totalmente imposible
meses atrás lo que ha hecho pues que la
vida sea mucho mejor Aunque ellos siguen
insistiendo que el problema de
electricidad Pero sobre todo de agua
hace que la vida siga siendo difícil